>> YES!
LOOK AT THAT.
[CHEERS]
>> I LOVE IT.
LET IT WATCH OVER ME.
FEELS SO GOOD.
>> SORRY, IT'S THURSDAY, WHICH
MEANS TOMORROW IS FRIDAY, AND
THEN THE WEEKEND, AND MY FRIENDS
SAY I LEARNED NOTHING AT
BERKELEY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> GREG: I LOVE A GOOD CALENDAR.
SO THE CDC NEEDS A MAKEOVER
WORSE THAN JOY BAYHAR.
CDC STANDS FOR THE CENTERS FOR
DISEASE CONTROL BUT WHAT DID IT
CONTROL REALLY DURING THE
PANDEMIC?
NOTHING.
INSTEAD IT BECAME ANOTHER
BLOATED ARM OF THE BUREAUCRATIC
MACHINE, A POLITICAL ENTITY
MAKING POLITICAL PRONOUNCEMENTS
AND PROTECTING ITS POLITICAL
ALLIES.
SO NO SURPRISE DURING THE
PANDEMIC THEY WERE MORE OF A
CRAP SHOW THAN A LEAKY FLEET
ENEMA.
[LAUGHTER]
>> GREG: SO THEY NEEDS TO CHANGE
AND WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT A
HALF ASS TRANSITION.
I'M TALKING ABOUT A HUNDRED
PERCENT MAKEOVER, AND A THINK
TANK AGREES WITH ME SAYING THE
CDC NEEDS A FULL RESET BECAUSE
IT NO LONGER CAN BE TRUSTED TO
HANDLE GLOBAL PANDEMICS.
HELL, AT THIS POINT, IT CAN'T BE
TRUSTED TO HANDLE AN OUTBREAK OF
DANDRUFF OR ATHLETE'S FOOT.
I WOULDN'T TRUST THEM TO CURE
DISCO FEVER.
YET, THEY CALL EVERYTHING A
HEALTH THREAT FROM RACISM TO
CLIMATE CHANGE.
ACCORDING TO THEM ANYTHING THAT
THEY DON'T LIKE COULD BE A
HEALTH RISK.
HOW CONVENIENT IS THAT?
I'M SURPRISED THEY AREN'T
DEMANDING WARNING LABELS ON
REPUBLICANS.
YET THEY MISS THE THINGS THAT
ARE KILLING US BY THE MILLIONS.
NO WONDER THE OBESITY EPIDEMIC
HAS GOTTEN OUT OF CONTROL.
THAT PICTURE MUST HAVE SHOWED UP
BY ACCIDENT.
ALTHOUGH SOMEBODY GET THEM MORE
OATS.
THE CENTER FOR STRATEGIC AND
INTERNATIONAL STUDIES STATES THE
CDC HAS ENTERED A MOMENT OF
PERIL AND HAS SUFFERED A SHARP
DECLINE IN POPULAR TRUST AND
CONFIDENCE.
BUT WAIT.
ARE WE TALKING ABOUT THE CDC OR
JUST ABOUT EVERYTHING THESE
DAYS?
THAT ONE LINE COULD APPLY TO
EVERY MAJOR INSTITUTION.
WELL, EXCEPT FOR THE GUTFELD!
INSTITUTE FOR AWESOME QUADS AND
ABS.
YOU CAN STILL TRUST THEM.
GOOD PEOPLE.
AN EXCELLENT WHIRLPOOL BATHS.
LOTS OF PRIVACY IF YOU KNOW WHAT
I MEAN BUT IT'S TRUE, CDC'S
HANDLING OF THE COVID REALLY PUT
IT ON THE MAP THE SAME WAY JFK'S
ASSASSINATION PUT THE BLAZEZA ON
THE MAP.
IT'S A STRETCH.
THE REPORT ALSO SUGGESTS HE
NEEDS TO CHANGE HOW HE DIRECTS
DATA AND BE MORE FLEXIBLE WITH
ITS BUDGET.
WOW, THAT'S BRILLIANT.
THAT'S LIKE SAYING JEFFREY
DAHMER'S PROBLEM WAS HIS CHOICE
OF CONDIMENTS.
THE REPORT ADDS, THE CDC RESET
IS A MATTER OF NATIONAL
SECURITY.
THE LEADERSHIP NEEDS TO PROVE
ITS HEAD IS FULLY IN THE REFORM
GAME BUT TRUE POWER TO CHANGE
LIES AT THE WHITE HOUSE, WHICH
MEANS THEY WANT THE CDC DO MOVE
ITS HEADQUARTERS FROM ATLANTA TO
DC, AND WHY?
SO JOE BIDEN CAN SCREW IT UP
FROM THE COMFORT OF HIS OWN
ABORN STAIR LIFT?
A MOVE TO WASHINGTON ONLY MAKES
SENSE IF YOU THINK CARJACKING A
GREAT WAY TO MEET STRANGERS.
SO WHILE I AGREE THAT THE CDC IS
AS BAD AS THE DISEASE IS, THAT
IT'S MEANT TO CONTROL I'M NOT
SURESEN NILTY IS THE RIGHT
ANSWER.
WHAT IS?
YOU NEED TO BRING SOMEONE IN WHO
IS FAMILIAR WITH CLEANING HOUSE.
YES.
I MEAN A WOMAN.
[OH]
>> GREG: TERRIBLE BUT WHAT YOU
REALLY NEED IS SOMEONE WHO HAS
NO PROBLEMS DISMISSING LAYERS OF
REDUNDANT FLABBY BUREAUCRACY.
ESSENTIALLY WE NEED TO CLONE
ELON MUSK BECAUSE HE GETS I.
YOU RUN INTO FLABLEM EVERYWHERE
IN GOVERNMENT.
IT'S AN ADMINISTRATIVE
BUREAUCRAC
BUREAUCRACY.
IF YOU NOTICE EVERYTHING ABOUT
HEALTH TOOK A BACK SEAT TO
ENHANCE THE MEDIA'S FOOT PRINT.
BEING ON TV WAS MORE IMPORTANT
THAN FIGHTING TB.
DR. FAUCI WAS ON SCREEN MORE
THAN OUR ADS FOR RELIEF FACTOR,
AND NOWHERE NEAR AS GOOD FOR
YOU.
THE ONLY HEALTH HE IMPROVED WAS
THE HEALTH OF HIS EGO.
SO IT'S NOT JUST THE PANDEMIC
MISTAKES BECAUSE WE ALL MADE
THEM.
IT'S ABOUT WHY THERE WERE SO
MANY AND SO MANY BY THE EXPERTS.
WHY IS THAT?
IT'S OBVIOUS.
POLITICS INFECTED IT.
AS THE CDC INSULLYING THE
TEACHER'S UNION AND IDENTITY
MERCHANTS RATHER THAN GIVING
REAL HEALTH ADVICE THAT COULD
HAVE SAVED LIVES.
SUDDENLY THEY WERE MAKING
SWEEPING PRONOUNCEMENTS ABOUT
EVERY LIBERAL CAUSE.
EVERYTHING BECAME A HEALTH
CRISIS.
RACISM, ENVIRONMENT, GUN CONTROL
AND YET FENTANYL SLIDES RIGHT BY
THEM JUST LIKE OBESITY AND
SUGAR.
YES, I THINK IT'S TIME FOR THE
CDC TO DO SOME SERIOUS SOUL
SEARCHING IF THEY HAVE ONE AND
MAYBE COME UP WITH A VACCINE
THAT FIGHTS POLITICS.
[APPLAUSE]
>> GREG: TONIGHT'S GUESTS, HE'S
NOT A COP ANYMORE BUT I HOPE HE
STILL STOPS TO FRISK ME.
FORMER NYPD FOUNDER --
[APPLAUSE]
>> GREG: THAT WAS HARD.
IF HE'S HERE THAT MEANS THE SALE
AT JAY KRUG MUST BE OVER.
GUY VIN SENT.
[APPLAUSE]
>> GREG: HER BACKGROUND CHECK IS
MORE FLAGS THAN A TRUMP RALLY.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT --
[APPLAUSE]
>> GREG: AND THE LAST TIME HE
PLAYED TWISTER, HE KILLED
SOMEONE.
MY MASSIVE SAID KICK AND THE
HEAVYWEIGHT CHAMPION TYRUS.
[APPLAUSE]
>> GREG: I JUST WANT -- I WANT
TO PUT UP GUY AND PAUL.
CAN YOU PUT THEM UP SIDE BY
SIDE.
ISN'T THIS WONDERFUL?
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME IN MY
CAREER THAT GUESTS CAME IN THE
EXACT SAME JACKET.
WHO WORE IT BETTER?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> DON'T ANSWER THAT.
>> I THINK YOU GUYS LOOK LIKE
REALLY HIP, REAL ESTATE AGENTS,
FROM DOWNTOWN, TRYING TO SELL A
LOT OF, AND THEN YOU MEET AND
FALL IN LOVE.
>> WHO TOLD THEM, YOU TOLD THEM?
[LAUGHTER]
>> ALL RIGHT.
LET'S DO THE STORY.
>> GREG: GUY, WHAT DO YOU MAKE
OF THIS?
IS THIS EVER POSSIBLE?
CAN YOU RESET ANYTHING IN
GOVERNMENT?
>> FIRST OF ALL CAN I SAY WE DID
LIKE THE SPIDERMAN MEME IN THE
GREEN ROOM.
BROOKS BROTHERS, BY THE WAY.
SPONSOR US, YOU COWARDS.
>> GREG: YES.
>> SO A COUPLE OF MONTHS AGO AT
THIS POINT, GOVERNOR DeSANTIS
DOWN IN FLORIDA ROLLED OUT THIS
PLAN THAT HE WAS GOING TO CREATE
LIKE AN ALTERNATE CDC TO LOOK
INTO DID CDC RECOMMENDATIONS AND
PEEL WENT CRAZY OVER THIS, LIKE
HE WAS BESMIRKING THE FINE
REPUTATION OF THIS INSTITUTION,
AND IT'S LIKE DO YOU HEAR
YOURSELVES.
>> PEOPLE DON'T TRUST THE CDC
ANYMORE.
I THINK IT WOULD BE HEALTHY TO
HAVE SOMEONE COME IN AND EITHER
SHAKE IT UP IN A MAJOR WAY OR DO
WHAT DeSANTIS HAS DONE, CREATE
AN ALTERNATIVE TO GIVE DIFFERENT
IDEAS.
AND IT SHOULD BE, YOU KNOW,
RIGOROUS AND MEDICALLY BASED AND
FOLLOW THE DATA UNLIKE WHAT THE
CDC DID UNFORTUNATELY TOO OFTEN
ON COVID.
>> I THINK THEY SHOULD FOCUS
MAINLY ON BALANCE OF NATURE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> GREG: PAUL, WELCOME TO THE
SHOW.
FIRST TIME, VERY EXCITED.
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THE CDC.
WHAT GETS ME PISSED OFF MORE
THAN ANYTHING IS THE REAL HEALTH
STUFF THEY MISSED, BUT THEN THEY
CHASE THE ATTENTION SEEKING
MEDIA ISSUES LIKE GUN CONTROL,
RACISM, AND CLIMATE CHANGE.
>> THINK ABOUT HOW MANY PEOPLE
WE HAVE DEDICATED TO THIS.
WE HAVE CDC.
FAUCI IS NOT CDC, INFECTIOUS AND
DISEASE CONTROL, THEN YOU HAVE
THE SURGEON GENERAL, RACHEL
LEVINE.
YOU HAVE ALL OF THESE FEDERAL
HEALTH PEOPLE, NONE OF THEM SEEM
TO BE SYNCHRONIZED, AND IT JUST
CONTINUES TO GROW, RIGHT?
AND YET YOU HAVE ONE JOB AND YOU
BLEW IT SO NOW YOU'VE GOT THIS
OTHER -- BY THE WAY, ANY TIME
YOU SEE MORE THAN TWO FEDERAL
ACRONYMS IN A STORY, REACH FOR
YOUR WALLET.
ALL RIGHT?
BECAUSE YOU KNOW WHERE THIS IS
GOING, RIGHT?
SO WHAT DO THEY DO?
THEY COME OUT AND SAY WE DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH.
WE'VE GOT TO MAKE THIS THING
BIGGER.
WE NEED MORE COMPUTERS.
MORE PEOPLE.
AND THEN, OH, BY THE WAY, LET'S
MOVE IT TO D.C., BECAUSE THAT'S
A GREAT IDEA, NOTHING EVER GOES
WRONG INSIDE THE BELTWAY.
THEY NEVER COME IN AND SAY MAKE
IT MORE AGILE.
PARROT DOWN.
LESS.
ALWAYS BIGGER.
>> GREG: IT CAN ONLY GROW.
BY THE WAY, DIDN'T KNOW YOU WERE
FROM ENGLAND.
>> I DON'T GET IT.
>> I DIDN'T KNOW --
>> GREG: THAT'S THE THICKEST
BROOKLYN ACCENT I HAVE EVER
HEARD.
QUEENS.
>> BROOKLYN, QUEENS.
>> YOU PEOPLE.
>> THE WORD TODAY, BOYS AND
GIRLS, IS SARCASM.
[LAUGHTER]
>> SARCASM.
>> GREG: KAT, WOULD YOU LOVE TO
RESET ALL OF GOVERNMENT AND MAKE
IT SMALLER.
IS THIS JUST A PIPE DREAM, A
CRACK PIPE DREAM?
>> OKAY.
NO, I AGREE.
I DON'T THINK THE CDC NEEDS TO
DO BETTER.
I THINK IT NEEDS TO DO LESS.
I DON'T THINK THE PROBLEM WAS
THE PEOPLE IN THE CDC SO MUCH AS
PEOPLE ARE THE CDC.
SO THEY ARE PRONE TO THE SAME,
YOU KNOW, CORRUPTION
POSSIBILITIES, AND THE FACT THEY
ARE GOING TO MAKE MISTAKES JUST
LIKE ALL HUMANS ARE.
SO A LOT OF THIS STUFF COULD BE
DONE BY LOCAL OFFICIALS WHO KNOW
THEIR COMMUNITIES BEST AND
PRIVATE RESEARCHERS WHO AREN'T,
YOU KNOW, A PART OF THE
GOVERNMENT.
SO I DON'T THINK IT MATTERS WHO
IS IN CHARGE.
I JUST THINK IT NEEDS TO BE
SMALLER.
YOU GUYS A BUNCH OF COMMIES,
OKAY.
>> GREG: THAT WAS UNCALLED FOR,
KAT.
>> I'VE BEEN UP SINCE 5:30 IN
THE MORNING.
YOU'RE WELCOME, FOX AND FRIENDS.
THEY WERE NICE TO ME.
PEOPLE SMILE ON FOX AND FRIENDS.
PEOPLE SMILE.
THEY SAY, OH, THEY SAY -- THEY
SAY GOOD MORNING.
[APPLAUSE]
>> THEY SAY GOOD MORNING.
THEY SAY GOOD SEE YOU, KAT.
>> GREG: YOU KNOW?
BECAUSE THEY ARE DESPERATE.
>> WHAT DO I GET FROM YOU?
>> GREG: MOM AND DAD, STOP.
VERY UPSETTING.
>> THAT'S WHY I DRINK.
[LAUGHTER]
>> GREG: TYRUS?
>> WILL A RESET MAKE A
DIFFERENCE?
>> THAT'S HILARIOUS.
RESET LIKE A MAKEOVER.
>> GREG: YES.
>> WE'RE GOING TO BE THE KDK.
OOPS, MY BAD.
WE RUINED AMERICANS' LIVES.
CRUSHED FAMILIES FOREVER, LIED
THROUGH OUR TEETH, EXTORTED,
SHAMED, COST PEOPLE THEIR JOBS,
AND WE'RE GOING TO GET A
MAKEOVER.
WE'RE GOING TO TURN IT AROUND.
YOU CAN'T TURN IT AROUND.
ANYBODY WHO IS WORK FOR THE CDC
CAN, OR WAS WITH FAUCI, EVERYONE
IN THOSE PROGRAMS, SHOULD BE
FIRED.
AT THE VERY LEAST, IF NOT EVEN
BEING LOOKED AT INTO CRIMINAL
CHARGES BECAUSE THEY HAD
INFORMATION THAT COULD HAVE
HELPED AND THEY KEPT IT, BECAUSE
WHY?
YOU SAID IT IN MONOLOGUE.
THAT TV WAS NICE.
HE WAS THROWING PITCHES OUT AT
BASEBALL GAMES.
ALTHOUGH THE WORST PITCH I HAVE
EVER SEEN IN MY LIFE.
HE WAS ON TALK SHOWS AND BECOME
COMPARED TO BRAD PITT.
>> GREG: THAT'S RIGHT.
>> SO WHY WOULD HE GIVE ALL OF
THAT UP?
HE BETRAYED SCIENCE FOR HIMSELF.
SO, MAKEOVER, NO.
BURN TO THE GROUND AND START
OVER.
>> GREG: N